hello and welcome to see you're playing
fish puppy here with white and looks
like a benoni and see what fish puppy is
up to a 6 a-6 looks very slow okay I go
where therefore I don't know and I know
if I've immediately here's a little bit
little bit harsh probably so it's
developed first yeah so okay let's go
eat five I don't want to think about
this for too long if I don't do it I
might have to face some peace only five
later so let's just open up the position
especially we have three maybe no way I
take up six then
Jim not sure what is doing now we should
be to Queenie to definitely looks better
for wine if not more than that but quite
sure what is the move is actually then
what is he doing now Queen to e7
something like that mmm he has to do
something out of the ordinary here bow
so keep ship ship for doesn't do the
trick I can take g74 porn but I think
that this should be good right just keep
the keep the pressure on so I Queen
takes Queen takes Queen is 794 check
threatening 926
96 any what does he do now I also
threatened e6 ok disick screen e6 is
still kind of acceptable Wow why is that
possible I guess it isn't a d6 queen is
695 should win a piece on all night c5
it was it was lost anyway black resins
very risky opening it with a 6 i'm not
sure that i played it played it well
yeah for hmm i know that f 4 is a move
even against Bishop e7 so it should be
more dangerous after a six if I yeah
Bishop takes was interesting I thought I
can take here but now the engine points
out that cream cakes as possible and
this isn't that great I mean this is
check this is some kind of compensation
but not not great hmm yeah this however
yeah computer yeah and the computer
wants to go Queenie seven I thought that
was the only move that still on fights
and takes oops and castles is good and
here I have this this thing coming
probably yeah why does a lot better but
at least black is still continuing I
think here Chan up to 94 I don't think
you can continue this so minus 2.5
according to the coma 96 is too strong
it wants to play chess check yeah okay
that's a it's a disaster like it's
totally uncommon it and velu stuff okay
well thanks for watching